وامام تخبط المعارضه التركيه بدا اردوغان
حمله انتخابيه ضد منافسا غائب والاسلحه
كثيره الاقتصاد واهمها وهو الذي كان نقطه
ضعف في ولايته السابقه اجراءات بنكهه
انتخابيه زياده الحد الادنى للاجور ليبلغ
450 دولارا واضافه الى خفض سن التقاعد وهو
القرار الذي استفاد منه اكثر من مليونير
عامل ضخوا الاموال بسخاء حل مؤقت وسيؤدي
فقط لسياده التضخم بعد اشهر قليله السياسه
الخارجيه سلاح اخر ارتفعت شعبيه اردوغان
بسببها رفض رفض اردوغان انضمام السويد
وفنلندا للنيتو ولعب دور الوسيط بين روسيا
والدول الغربيه وايضا تجنب الانضمام
للعقوبات المفروضه على روسيا قرار جعل
تركيا ملاذا للاستثمارات الروسيه لكن رغم
ذلك ومع قرب الانتخابات قدم اردوغان
تنازلات غير مسبوقه مثل الغائه سحب رخصه
القياده واعفائه طلبه الجامعات من فوائد
القرود والهدف هنا طبعا استقطاب فئه
الشباب والاستطلاعات تشير الى انهم الاقل
مسانده لاردوغان سته ملايين منهم سينتخبون
للمره الاولى ويمثلون 15 من اجمالي
الناخبين المطالب الاكثر شعبيه للمعارضه
وهي اعاده ثلاثه ملايين ونصف المليون لاجئ
سوري دفعت اردوغان لمحاوله التقارب مع
النظام السوري والاتفاق على عوده المشروطه
للاجئين وسنفصل هذا الموضوع غدا في الساعه
ستون لكن بالحديث عن المعارضه قدمت خدمه
اخرى لاردوغان اتحاد سته احزاب رئيسيه
افرز برنامجا موحدا لكنه ما زال عاجزا عن
التوصل لتوافق بشان مرشحها اتحاد المعارضه
او طاوله السته رغم انه تحالف للعلمانيين
فيتامينا لتيارات الاسلاميه وحتى رفاق
اردوغان السابقين اغلق الابواب امام
الاحزاب المحسوبه على الاكراد وهو اقصاء
لجزء من اصوات المعارضه لاردوغان لكن
التحالف قوته تكمن في البرنامج بعيدا عن
هويه مرشحها
[موسيقى]
يعني تركيا
دبوس سيستمنت نيسان
[موسيقى]